let's say i have some weak acid i'll
call it h a
h a a is a place holder for uh
really a whole set of of elements that i
could put there could be fluorine it
could be an ammonium molecule if you add
an h it becomes ammonium so this isn't
any particular element i'm talking about
this is just kind of a general way of
writing a an acid and let's say it's in
equilibrium
it's in
equilibrium with
of course and you've seen this multiple
times
a proton and all this is in an aqueous
solution
aqueous
between this proton jumping off of this
and its conjugate base a minus and we
could have also written a a base
equilibrium where we say the conjugate
base could disassociate or it could
essentially grab a hydrogen from the
water and create oh and we've done that
multiple times but
that's not the point of this video so
let's just think a little bit about what
would happen to this equilibrium if we
were to stress it in some way and you
can already imagine that i'm about to
touch on le chatelier's principle which
essentially just says look if you stress
an equilibrium in any way the
equilibrium moves in such a way to
relieve that stress so let's say that
the stress that i apply to this system
let's say that the stress that i apply
is i'm going to add
i'm going to add let me do a different
color
i'm going to add some strong base
that's too dark
i'm going to add some n a
o h
and we know this is a strong base when
you put it in an aqueous solution the
sodium part just kind of dissociates but
the more important thing you have all
this oh in the solution which wants to
grab hydrogens away so when you add this
oh to the solution what's going to
happen for every mole that you add so
for every not even just mole for every
molecule you add of this
into the solution
it's going to eat up a molecule of
hydrogen
right so for example if you had one mole
of hydrogen molecules in your solution
and you added one mole of sodium
hydroxide to your solution
right when you do that all of this is
going to react with all of that and it's
and the ohs are going to react with the
h's so just so you be and form water and
they'll both just kind of disappear into
the solution they didn't disappear they
all turned into water and so all of this
hydrogen will go away or at least the
hydrogen that was initially there that
one mole of hydrogens will disappear so
what will what should happen to this
reaction well we know this is an
equilibrium reaction so as these
hydrogens disappear
as these hydrogens disappear
because this is an equilibrium reaction
or because this is a weak base more of
this is going to be converted
or the more of this is going to be
converted into these two products to
kind of make up for that loss of
hydrogen and you can even play with it
on the mat so this is going to so this
hydrogen goes down initially and you
know all of this equilibrium then it
starts getting to equilibrium very fast
but this is going to go down
this is going to go up
and then this is going to go down less
because sure when you put the sodium
hydroxide there it just ate up all of
the hydrogens but then you have this you
can kind of use this this spare hydrogen
capacity here to produce hydrogens and
when these disappear this weak base will
disassociate more the equilibrium will
move more in this direction
and then you'll have so immediately this
will eat all of that but then when the
equilibrium moves in that direction some
of the a lot of the hydrogen will be
replaced so if you think about what's
happening if i just threw if i just
threw this sodium hydroxide in water
so if i just did
naoh
in an aqueous solution so that's just
throwing it in water
that disassociates completely into the
sodium
sodium cation
and hydroxide anion
and so you all of a sudden you would
immediately increase the the quantity of
ohs by essentially the amount of the
number of moles of sodium hydroxide
you're adding and you'd immediately
increase the ph right remember when you
increase the amount of oh you would
decrease the poh
right and that's just because it's the
negative log or so if you increase o h
you're decreasing poh and you're
increasing
ph
and just to think o h is you're making
it more basic
more basic and a high ph is also very
basic if you have a mole of this you end
up with a ph of 14 and if you had a
strong acid not a strong base you'd end
up with a ph of zero
and and you know hopefully you're
getting a little bit familiar with that
concept right now but
if it confuses you just play around with
the logs a little bit and you'll
eventually get it but just to get back
to the point if i if if you just did
this in water you immediately get a
super high ph because the oh
concentration goes through the roof but
if you do it here if you apply the the
sodium hydroxide to this solution the
solution that contains
a weak
acid and its conjugate base
the weak acid and its conjugate base
what happens
sure it immediately reacts with all of
this hydrogen and eats it all up but
then you have this extra supply here
that just keeps providing more and more
hydrogens and it'll make up a lot of the
loss so essentially the the stress won't
be as bad and over here you you you
dramatically increase increase the ph
when you just throw it on water here
you're going to increase the ph by a lot
lot lot less and in future videos will
actually do the math of how much less
it's increasing the ph but the way you
could think about it is kind this is
kind of a shock absorber for ph it even
though you threw this strong base onto
this into this solution it didn't
increase the ph as much as you would
have expected and you can make it the
other way if i just wrote this exact
same reaction as a basic reaction
and remember this is this the same thing
so if i just wrote this as
a
minus i just wrote this conjugate base
is in
equilibrium with the conjugate base
grabbing some water from the surrounding
aqueous solution everything we're
dealing with right now is in an aqueous
solution and of course that water that
it grabbed from is now going to be an oh
remember these are just equivalent
reactions here i'm writing it as an
acidic reaction here i'm writing it as a
basic reaction but they're equivalent
now if you were to add a strong at a
strong acid to the solution what would
happen so if i were to throw hydrogen
chloride into this
well hydrogen chloride if you just throw
it into straight up water without this
solution it would completely
disassociate into a bunch of hydrogens
and a bunch of chlorine anions
chlorine anions and it would immediately
make it very acidic you would get you'd
get to a very low ph if you had a mole
of this if your concentration was one
molar then this will go to a ph of zero
but what happens if you add hydrochloric
acid
to this solution right here this one
that has this weak base and its
conjugate weak acid
well all that all of these hydrogen
protons that disassociate from the
hydrochloric acid
are all going to react with these ohs
you have here and they're just going to
cancel each other out they're just going
to merge with these and turn into water
and become part of the aqueous solution
so this the ohs are going to go down
initially
but then you have this reserve of weak
base here and we legit talia's principle
tells us look if we have a stressor that
is decreasing our overall concentration
of oh
then the reaction is going to move in
the direction that relieves that stress
so the reaction is going to go in that
direction so you're going to have more
of our weak base
turning into a weak acid and producing
more oh so the
so the ph won't go down as much as you
would expect if you just threw this in
water this is going to lower the ph but
then you have more o h that could be
produced as this guy grabs more and more
hydrogens from the water so the way to
think about it is kind of like a like a
cushion or a spring on in terms of
what a strong acid or base could do to
the solution
and that's why it's called a buffer
a buffer
buffer because it provides a cushion
on acidity if you add a strong base to
water you immediately increase its ph or
you decrease its acidity dramatically
but if you add a strong base to a buffer
because of the of le chatelier's
principle essentially you're not going
to affect the ph as much same thing if
you add an acid to that same buffer it's
not going to affect the ph as much as
you would have expected if you thrown
that acid in water because the the
equilibrium reaction can always kind of
refill the amount of oh that you lost in
the if you're adding acid or it can
refill the amount of hydrogen you lost
if you're adding a base and that's why
it's called a buffer provides a cushion
so it gives some stability to the
solutions ph
and so the actual definition really is
just a solution of the definition of a
buffer is just a solution of a weak acid
in equilibrium with its conjugate weak
base that's what a buffer is and it's
called a buffer because it provides you
this kind of cushion of ph it's kind of
a stress absorber or a shock absorber
for the acidity of a solution
now with that said let's explore a
little bit the math of a buffer which is
really just the math of a of a weak acid
so if we rewrite the equation again so
h a is in equilibrium
everything's in an aqueous solution
with
hydrogen
and its conjugate base
we know that there's an equilibrium
constant for this we've done
many videos on that the equilibrium
constant here is equal to the
concentration
of our hydrogen proton times the con the
concentration of our conjugate base
when i say concentration i'm talking
molarity
moles per liter divided by the
concentration of our weak acid
now let's take the log or let's take the
negative log of both sides of this
equation actually let me do something
let's solve for hydrogen concentration
because what i want to do is i want to
figure out a formula and we'll call it
the henderson hasselbach formula which
which a lot of books want you to
memorize which i don't think you should
i think you should always just be able
to go from the this kind of basic
assumption and get to it but let's solve
for the hydrogen so we can figure out a
relationship between ph and all the
other stuff that's in this formula so if
we want to solve for hydrogen we can
multiply both sides by the reciprocal of
this right here
and you get
hydrogen concentration
and i'm flipping well let me just do ka
times i'm multiplying both sides times
the reciprocal of that so times
eight the concentration of our weak acid
divided by the concentration of our weak
base
is equal to
our concentration
of
our hydrogen
fair enough
now let's take the negative log of both
sides
so the negative log let me do that
negative log
of
all of that stuff of
your
acidic equilibrium constant
times
times make sure let me see what green
was i using
times
h a
our weak acid divided by our weak base
is equal to the negative log of our
hydrogen concentration which is just our
ph right
negative log of hydrogen concentration
is that's the definition
of ph
and i'll write the p and the h in
different colors so you know that p is
just means negative log
minus log that's all a base 10. let's
see if we can simplify this anymore
so our logarithmic properties we know
that when you take the when you when you
take the log of something and you
multiply it that's the same thing as
taking the log of this plus the log of
that so this can be simplified to
minus log
of our
ka
minus
minus
the log
minus the log of
our weak acid concentration divided by
its conjugate base concentration
is equal to
the ph
now this is just the pka of our weak
acid which is just a negative log of z
of its equilibrium
constant so this is just the pka
and the minus log of h a over a if you
what we can do is we could take
make this a plus and just take this to
the minus 1 power right that's just
another logarithm property and you can
review the logarithm videos if that
confused you and this to the minus 1
power just means invert this so you
could say plus
the logarithm
of our conjugate base concentration
divided by the weak acid concentration
is equal to
the ph and this right here this is
called the henderson-hasselback equation
henderson hasselback and i really
encourage you not to memorize it because
if you do attempt to memorize it you're
and within a few hours you're going to
forget whether this was a plus over here
you're going to forget this and you're
going to forget whether you put the a
minus or the h a on the numerator the
denominator and if you forget that it's
fatal the better thing is to just start
from your base assumptions and if you
weren't and trust me it took me a couple
of minutes to do it but if you just do
it really fast on paper and you don't
have to talk it through the way i did
it'll take you no time at all to come to
this equation it's much better than
memorizing it and you you won't forget
it when you're 30 years old but what's
useful about this well it immediately
relates ph
to our pka and this is a constant right
for an equilibrium plus the log of the
ratios between the at the acid and the
conjugate base so if i the more
conjugate base i have and the less acid
i have the more my ph is going to
increase right if this goes up and this
is going down my ph is going to increase
which makes sense because i have more
base in the solution and if i have the
inverse of that my ph is going to
decrease
now the the one thing that i find really
neat about this equation
let me rewrite it again ph
is equal to
pka which is a constant
plot you could look that up on wikipedia
for a certain temperature for a certain
molecule plus
the log
of our conjugate base divided by our
conjugate acid or the weak acid
this is
moles
of a minus divided by whatever volume
we're dealing with right
and this is
let me do another color moles
of our weak acid
divided by whatever volume so we have a
volume divided by a volume if we
multiply the numerator and the
denominator by volumes we get this
we can get rid of concentration and just
describe it in terms of
moles or just the number of molecules ph
is equal to
pk a
plus the log and inside here i'm just
multiplying the numerator and the
denominator by the volume and whatever
that is it's the same volume right
because they're in the same solution
so the log of
moles
of a minus
divided by
moles
of h a
now you're saying sal you get excited
too easily what's so amazing about that
think about it your ph now is a function
this is just a constant your ph is a
function of the absolute number of
molecules or the ratio of your molecules
of your conjugate base
to
the weak acid right
now what what's fascinating about that
that means that it's independent of
dilution it's independent of the volume
nowhere in this formula in no way when
you have this buffer solution
in no way is it dependent on volume on
on actual amount of of solution so to me
that's that's that's that's slightly
mind-blowing and i encourage you to to
send me to send me comments on why you
think that makes intuitive sense because
if i just think about okay you know ph
is hydrogen concentration
that's hydrogen concentration that's
hydrogen molecules per amount of volume
so i would have intuitively thought gee
if if i add a lot more volume to this
and i have the same amount of hydrogen
atoms then i'm not going to that then my
ph is going to go down because i'm going
to have less hydrogen per liter but it
turns out because of really because of
of the shetalia's principle that that's
not the case that if you increase the
volume somehow because of the shetalia's
principle the hydrogen concentration
adjusts so that the ph doesn't change
that the ph is independent on a buffer
solution which is just a solution of a
weak acid or base and its conjugate
the ph is independent of the volume of
the solution so you can evaporate some
of the water out you can add more water
to it not going to change the ph and
that to me is kind of the really amazing
takeaway of a buffer solution and
the henderson hasselbach equation